hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the final episode of five
nights at Freddy's 3 it's been a long
road but there's only one more thing to
do and it's actually quite a monumental
task I need to play the entire game
again and go through a very complicated
walkthrough that I found in order to
play all the secret hidden mini-games
that number that we found earlier when
we're trying to remember that was part
of one of the minigames but I need to go
back to the beginning of the game to be
able to get to all of them again and I
need to beat every level again which
shouldn't be bad because I beat
nightmare mode and I'm very skilled and
capable and smart and stuff enhancing
and also good at games so there's gonna
be a lot of cutting obviously I'm not
gonna make you see all of it but I'm
gonna try to be as concise and clear as
I can in everything that I'm doing so
that you guys aren't lost at any moment
because there is a ton of backstory and
easter-egg stuff to go on here but the
first night doesn't matter you don't
need to do anything on the first night
because the first night is irrelevant
irrelevant
night 1 spring-trap actually isn't here
so it's just me watching over the place
making sure no one sneaks in it makes
out in the dark corners of the place
it's actually good because it gets the
player adjusted to the environment
without giving them a threat he can
listen to the information without having
to worry about dying whereas in the
other nights you have to do both at the
same time and most the time you're just
gonna die anyway I only died because I
wanted you guys to hear what was going
on but that's besides the point
[Music]
so oddly enough these minigames here
don't lead a lot into what's going on in
the rest of the game unless there were
hints in these minigames as to what you
needed to do in the future which there
might have been I did not explore the
entirety of the facility while I was
playing as Freddie I did find the
numbers which were a clue and probably a
very vital component to be able to get
into the minigame that is going to be
shown later on Oh see it is a clue okay
BB
dbl click that means Balloon Boy
don't be lick [ __ ] okay but either way
this tells me that there's a clue the
clues were always here can that make so
much sense because in the last one I saw
shadow bonnie and shadow bonnie was
represented at the plushy on the desk I
don't even know if I told you guys about
that but there's a hidden plushie on the
desk of shadow Bonnie oh that's so cool
okay so there were clues it wasn't
totally hidden an unknown that's amazing
now what the fear crafters are debating
is whether or not this shadow Freddy is
actually the purple guy or if he's
trying to lead people to go here because
this is the back room that people were
talking about I felt the boarded up
areas were the back room but this is the
area that animatronics can't go that's
why there's an error he can't go back
there guy and then shut up I don't need
to talk to you thank you I'm done with
your conversation BAM there we go there
we go see ah
BB's err adventure oh it's like a
fun-filled magical place I hope I don't
have any diabolical nightmares that are
gonna be more diabolical okay so the
next thing that you need to do is you
need to not go through that door you
need to jump out here and then this own
okay I thought I was gonna go somewhere
else where is lovely
I'm glad balloon boy has his bow
yeah things go a little bit wrong when
you're playing these hit minigames and
the fact that it's a hidden minigame
with a hidden outcome beyond it and what
is that tree what are their crying
balloon boys
is that a mangle tree oh goody goody
gumdrops can't wait for this final
balloon it's gonna be so magical and
solve all my problems oh there we go so
now we can actually play the game
because what that did was that freed
balloon boys soul or something or I
don't even know the only reason I have
my mouse in this particular video and
not the other ones was because I wanted
you guys to see exactly what I was
clicking on hey buddy hey Seenu oh come
on now what is the what how did I how do
I fail okay
how did I fail on night 2 I am great at
this game
do-do-do-do-do whoa that's that's
different why is this this this wasn't
here before
[Music]
wait a minute this isn't making sense
how the hell is this hello hello this
wasn't here before this is totally
different
hello crying child mothers debate on
whether the crying child actually
represents the oh hey oh no oh no I
broke the game I broke the game I broke
it how did I broke it oh how could I
have broken it okay we're back but it's
actually good that we're back because I
missed a crucial step it's good that I
didn't continue with that because I
messed up there what I needed to do is I
needed to continue forward with another
minigame in the same night and not just
this night but I don't know how this
would have been possible because there
was no clue to this action no I don't
need to talk with you right now
I've got problems to worry about but
first I need to do this you need to
click top left bottom right bottom or
bottom up on right top
there we go okay sorry
it was bottom top left bottom left okay
so what you're supposed to do here is
you're supposed to collect your pieces
without this kid touching you which is
probably in relation to the five nights
at Freddy's 2 thing where mangle was a
creative project for kids in that he was
ready to be assembled Oh No
okay I screwed that up bad games bad
games you're just seeing an amalgamation
of my failures but the secret here is
you don't need to go through that exit
and I will admit I did not figure this
stuff out by myself I've I've mentioned
that before I am NOT the one that
figured all this out and I don't claim
to be like I'm building this off of
other people's works and I whoa hi there
what the hell are you kind of diabolical
nightmare does this all represent I mean
this is all part of like the lost souls
of these children in that that like
they're in an eternal hell like in
purgatory just filled with hate I mean I
don't even know how mango and the the
toy the toy things play into like kids
souls but like it's just all weird to
see because the original original
original took place like 50 something
years ago because it was before the
first game was when the second game took
place but the the suits were haunted
before that so the kids died ages and
ages ago and that's really sad to think
about they've been trapped for so long
with so much hate and and in the daytime
somehow they still entertain children
probably because they didn't want to
ever hurt children okay so I got the
cake and the cake is important because
you need the cable to do something that
I'm gonna show you in just a second okay
so use the cake to comfort the crying
child hello that's a good thing there
now I just gotta beat this game so it's
like cosmic logic that I didn't beat it
last time I died because I was stupid
and ignorant or something but I'm gonna
be to this side oh there he is okay he's
way in the back there
I see ok these nights are long I forgot
how long they're so it's like just like
a panicked induced state of horrifying
this and then you have to just do
everything else ok so this will lead to
another clue as to what I'm supposed to
do in the next one I think this is
actually where I found the code wasn't
it like I'm not sure but maybe oh yeah
that was it the cupcakes I run I read
this in the walk forever at the hole
through the hole walk first
but the cupcakes you need to click the
four cupcakes and that's clue right
there they were all clues they were all
clues leading me to know what to do I
just didn't know how to interpret them
so kudos to everyone they figured it out
it but it's not as deep a mystery as I
thought it was because hey these clues
are kind of straightforward except for
one of them you'll see what I mean
wouldn't you see that okay so in night 3
you need to actually click on the
cupcakes and they're in this order
they're in - I see your eyes there I saw
these things the entire time I just
didn't know what they were supposed to
be doing like especially in 93 I saw
them and I didn't know what to make of
them there we go we get to chicas party
which is so much fun and I'm so eager
that actually looks like toy chica there
man is that what they originally were
like we were originally boys I couldn't
oh wait no it's right here there's
something else that needs to be done you
need to go yeah that's right because
these crying children aren't actually
dead children they're just crying sons
of [ __ ] you need to go over here to
the actual crying job not just a whining
brat over there you want some cupcake
it's okay yeah the phantom balloon boy
because I haven't yet put all their
souls to rest but hey it's progress it's
good progress I did good
maybe
[Music]
I mean there's no point in discussing
how the game is played I already know
how to beat it so alright so this is
where the next clue came into play three
nine five two four eight those were the
numbers that we were supposed to
remember three nine five two four eight
now how they're used is going to be very
confusing because if you didn't even
know about her if you didn't even think
to try like why would you think to try
there's no reason for this to make sense
based on what I was seeing in the
walkthrough but we'll get to that in
just a second error error okay so this
next one is very very very very
confident three nine five two four eight
and here is what I know because this is
a son of a [ __ ] this group of panels
actually yeah this group panels three
nine five two four eight will lead you
to this for some reason like I don't
even know what the hell's going on here
but look it's it's golden Freddy and
it's the golden Bonnie that literally is
a golden Bonnie but that was what the
original thing was I don't know why I
don't even know why why in the world
like the murder of the children happened
in five nights at Freddy's 2 that was
discussed like that's what happened like
that's what happened
but what happened in the original one
that caused these animatronics to be
possessed Balazs okay so anyway we
supposed to do is just let's go here
[Music]
[Applause]
alrighty then so that was supposed to
happen that's what was supposed to
happen you're supposed to glitch out
like that and then in the end you stay
here oh no yeah you're supposed to just
go over it I guess I'm not entirely sure
this is all new to me like I just read
walkthrough I don't know exactly what
I'm supposed to do whenever I'm supposed
to do it I know you're not supposed to
go through that door
there was another way there was another
way oh my okay then so how am I supposed
to be able to get up more I know I'm
supposed to be able to glitch but I
doubt I'm supposed to be able to no no
no no I didn't want to do that do it
again three nine five two four eight
three nine five two four eight Oh
finally Jesus sounds complicated the
walkthrough is wrong because it told you
to jump right when you're supposed to
jump left at the door with the eggs and
we just try to get down here
[Music]
it's filled with walked to the rights
but jumped to the left and it doesn't
make any sense because I think they got
the rights and left confused okay so now
now we should be getting somewhere
because I don't know how this got to
where we are but wait yes yeah
finally holy crap I don't know how
anyone could solve this one because it
was so unbelievably convoluted actually
human ingenuity of course we could
resolve it I just gotta beat the fourth
night good god that was incredible
but why was golden Freddy the
representative in that game so bizarre
I'm assuming that like the facial
recognition software and crap like that
that was all [ __ ] said by the phone
guy just because in that day and age
they couldn't do that that wasn't
technologically feasible
there is something other going on with
these animatronics that is unknown and
frankly I'd like to know what because
this is a mystery that needs to be
solved
he likes to climb in the quick one but
good thing he stops to look at how
pretty I am in the camera
[Music]
me being a dingus okay so this is where
this makes sense that's shadow Bonnie
there and shadow Bonnie is actually an
interesting character that was almost
overlooked in the second game because he
so rarely appeared and I don't know how
he works into this whole story of how
the children are rescued or whatever or
I mean this is weird that it's taken
upon me as a guy from the future or as
the character that's been playing this
whole game the entire time just me as a
security guard security guard in general
[Music]
you weren't supposed to be there that's
not what happened that's totally
different
no I don't have time to listen what the
hell is that we're not gonna explain
that to me
okay shadow Bonnie's right here there we
go okay so shadow bunny is here and this
one's actually complicated shadow bonnie
is a horrifying looking creature even an
8-bit but that was weird he doesn't come
out of there the purple guy doesn't come
from there what the hell just happened
why did that happen I don't know okay
whatever whoa oh that's fun
okay so Oh
[Music]
okay oh-oh-oh
okay what the hell's going on here yeah
I think everyone at home would like to
know what the hell is happening also how
do I there's a way to there's a way to
get out of this I think oh oh oh maybe
through here because this was where the
exit would yeah okay
so if I just good there we go did I do
it did I do it there's another step
though there's another step because I
forgot what it actually was so one
second looks like okay camera three
there's a marionette picture okay camera
three marionette is that it that was it
okay that was it so the happiest day I
need to do something just kept go to the
exit oh oh are you an ally
were you a piggy Pig I guess I don't
want any cake Oh everyone's so happy Oh
everyone's having such a good time
oh no you want some cake cake the last
child would the fifth child was golden
Freddy because that confused me in the
end screen for the bad ending quote
unquote there was a there was a fifth
animatronic head in the background I
think that was going Freddy and golden
Freddy was the one possessed by the
actual kid but he was just in spirit for
him he didn't actually have a suit so he
just was represented by the one that
killed the kids in the golden Bonnie
suit I think killed him in the golden
Freddy suit and that's why kind of last
time that one either way it's all very
horrible all horrible every oven is
horrible
we went all the way up to ten vent
goddammit son of a [ __ ] okay so let's
get this done oh [ __ ] I'm dead I'm dead
already so I don't need to worry about
that
but if he went into event of all those
loud noises were playing I'm gonna be
very pissed he win and goddamn back of
course of course he did
which one which one the one that can
kill me there is seal you up come on
come back come back come back gasps oh
please tell me I got that good Jesus
Christ okay so long as he went back to
two I should be okay does he oh [ __ ] in
a doc go to 2 please go to 2 oh [ __ ]
here I'm dead I'm [ __ ] dead [ __ ]
dead [ __ ] dead
I'm just gonna god damn it [ __ ] I knew
he went back by my camera [ __ ] Oh
Gracie and everything fell a [ __ ]
part time for you
but the ventilation was already going
sauce is doing it foxy thank you for the
roof rend li reminder that everything is
going horribly for me thank you
Mon any minute now yes god damn it ah I
don't know I still feel so good when I
win that it's like it's not scary you
know what this happens all the time I
played a new one of these games and it's
very scaring the because I've no idea
what's going on but oh man oh man oh man
oh man okay so now I play as the crying
child and this is what happened but I
didn't play any of the minigames
beforehand when I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna check that one hallway to see if
there's anything new now that I've done
everything and if there's not then I
know that I just need to go straight to
the thing okay there's nothing here
there's nothing there's nothing else to
find there's no other Easter eggs well
there might be other Easter eggs but I
have no idea if anyone has even tried to
find him yet but this is the way to go
this is what you're supposed to do and
this is how it's done not like that
running into a table but just about like
it's gonna happen soon there you are
yeah you better be sweating that soup
I'm assuming these are arcade cabinets
over
[Music]
and that's it yes it doesn't seem safe
the good end it says the end oh man oh
god I beat it I did it I didn't even do
it on my own I have everyone to credit
that came up with the strategy
beforehand I mean the clues were all
there so I'm sure a lot of people found
it out at the same time especially like
people that were streaming the game but
fantasy end of the game that is the end
of five nights at freddy as far as I
know like I don't even think that I want
there to be any more five nights at
Freddy's after this and I know a lot of
people are gonna be you know hashing out
the story and figuring out the details
and coming up with theories for ages and
ages and ages and they're gonna figure
out like what happened in the original
restaurant like the question still is
what happened in the original restaurant
but as it is right now
the spirits of the children have been
freed they are finally at rest and five
nights at Freddy's no longer has the
haunted animatronics that made it the
game that it is these animatronics have
finally been laid to rest and they can
finally be at peace once again and
there's got to be some extra stuff in
here I know I know there's got to be
extra like cheats fast Knights radar
aggressive no airs oh man there's
probably like a 20 mode in this alright
then that was really silly but either
way this was a really really interesting
interesting thing and I say interesting
more than like fun or terrifying or
something it was so interesting because
of the animalistic curiosity that it
brought out from the entire gaming
community like people can say whatever
they want about the game itself it's not
scary it's scary it's terrifying it's
not terrifying whatever it's a bad game
good game
doesn't matter what matters is the fact
that it brought about so much discussion
and so much curiosity it was the exact
right balance of terror and curiosity
the diving into what scares you most to
find out the truth and that's kind of
something Admiral about humanity in
general not that there was any danger in
reality but just the fact that so many
people like who hate horror games played
this just
because they wanted to know and so many
people still want to know just like I do
what the hell happened in that first
restaurant or why in the first place all
of these horrible things happen and what
could have possibly been done because
five nights at Freddy's 2 2 was a
prequel but it was not the first
restaurant these animatronic suits that
were had the toy versions made of him
came before and there's a mystery back
there but I don't think this series
needs another game one of the best parts
about this entire experience has been
the mystery and the solving it through
just observation and understanding and
finding secrets and I guarantee you
there are more secrets in here than have
been revealed in just this video so keep
an eye open there might be more down the
road but for right now for me and for
you guys that have joined me for this
entire adventure the millions and
millions of you that have watched these
videos I just want to say thank you so
much you've done an amazing thing for me
in supporting me and for those that have
found my channel I do horror games and
other silly games and stuff like that
I'm I'm just a pretty typical gaming
youtuber but I just wanted to say thank
you so much for picking my videos and
watching all the other ones because
there are some great videos out there so
thank you everybody somewhat for
watching this is the end of five nights
at Freddy's check out the other stuff
that I've done five nights at Freddy's
related to in the description below or
in the annotations over there and
there's gonna be an animation I know
sometime soon so wait for that anyway
thanks again everybody so much and as
always I will see you in the next movie
[Applause]